et nous accueillons notre invité du
samedi 20 heures ce soir lola dewaere
le dollar bonsoir de verre patrick
dewaere un nom qui résonne comme un
mythe au coeur de tous les cinéphiles
patrick dewaere révélé en 1974 dans les
valseuses de bertrand blier suicides et
8 ans et 25 films plus tard sans avoir
jamais eu le moindre césar lola vous
êtes la fille de patrick dewaere vous
êtes nommé aux césars et à 20 heures
vous nous raconterez votre vie
de l'adverbe rebond soir
alors vous êtes né le 4 décembre
1979 à boulogne-billancourt le ta fille
de l'acteur patrick dewaere et de
elisabeth malvina chalier dit elsa vous
avez une demi soeur angèle qui est la
fille de patrick dewaere et de miu miu
lors de votre père vous ne garder qu'un
flash vous habitez rue du moulin vert
dans l'appartement de la famille dans le
14e vous venez de casser une bouteille
sur le carrelage de la cuisine et votre
père vous gronde et vous donne une
fessée et votre mère essaie de
l'amadouer mais ma première fessée au
moins j'aurai ça donc comme souvenir
c'est la dernière et la dernière
c'est parce que c'est le plaisir de la
fessée à
cette époque patrick dewaere est au
sommet de sa gloire avec série noire est
au fond du trou avec l'héroïne prend
beaucoup d'héroïne a commencé en 1976
lors du tournage de la meilleure façon
de marcher et ça a été le début de sa
descente aux enfers est devenu impulsif
violent invivable n'est pas connu ça
mais je ne peux pas vous répondre parce
que les échanges en temps les gens qui
me parlent de ça autour de moi en
octobre 1981 il a révélé à un
journaliste du journal du dimanche la
date de son mariage avec elsa en lui
faisant promettre de ne pas en parler
évidemment le journal du dimanche fait
sa une la dessus et patrick dewaere le
père va casser la gueule au journaliste
qui fait qu'il est boycotté par la
presse à partir de là et quand on parle
du film on cite même pas son nom ou les
initiales
alors il est pas reconnue non plus par
le métier il a été nommé six fois aux
césars il n'a jamais été pris mais
pendant l'été 1981 de patrick dewaere
prépare le film de claude lelouch edith
et marcel où il joue le rôle du boxeur
marcel cerdan
lelouch lui fait promettre de décrocher
de l'hérault mais c'est pas facile parce
qu'à l'époque c'est vrai que l'héroïne y
en avait beaucoup plus que maintenant
donc il a du mal à décrocher c'est un
truc épouvantable
votre mère aussi tentent de décrocher
elle se réfugie en guadeloupe chez
coluche qui était le meilleur ami de
votre père
évidemment leur couple patrick votre
père est là votre mère souffre de leurs
différentes addictions et s'essouffler
un peu déjà non bah oui tout à fait
quand on était quand on est parti chez
michel fanget coluche
puis mon père était censé être en des
crocs et ma mère aussi
le 16 juillet 1982 patrick dewaere
appelle votre mère et lui demandent de
rentrer en métropole
elle lui répond qu'elle rentrera
uniquement lorsqu'il aura complètement
décroché de l'hérault en fait elle
voulait se protéger vous pourriez me
protéger
mais il ya pire lors de sa conversation
téléphonique avec votre maire patrick
soupçonne elsa et coluche d'être
ensemble quand on voit sa femme partir
comme ça fait son meilleur ami rami
qu'on veut parfum
on a dégoûté s'étaient fondés
elle rappelle mathilde raccrocher
patrick appelle son dealer mais le
dealer n'est pas à paris et à ce moment
là patrick dewaere votre père prend une
carabine 22 long rifle et se tire une
balle dans la bouche ironie du sort
c'est une carabine qui lui avait été
offerte par coluche
à la mort de votre père n'est pas encore
trois ans votre mère est incapable de
s'occuper de vous et vous retrouver chez
vos grands parents maternels un saint
lambert du lattay en maine-et-loire le
village où est enterré patrick dewaere
c'est sympa vos grands parents au bout
génial ouais un sens je ne serai pas
à votre grand père était centralien
notre grand-mère directrices d'écoles
catholiques
alors il donne une éducation à l'opposé
de ce qu'étaient devenus vos parents
évidemment
ça m'a permis de me structurer voilà
c'est bien auprès des cours de danse les
cours de pierre d'iodé ont été inscrits
par tous qu'on va cordée ont des cours
de flûte en avions fait traversière oui
mais tout le monde trouvait enfin mes
grands-parents qui m'aimait beaucoup
trouvaient que j'étais une virtuose de
la flûte traversière mais maintenant
quand je regardais les cassettes vidéos
jeux non non non non
non et alors vos grands parents sont
aussi obligés de vous protéger des
paparazzi vous cache dans la bagnole
c'est vrai qu'il avait été obligé
pour aller d'un point à l'autre bref en
voiture de me cacher mon cousin et moi
sous une couverture pour pas qu'on soit
photo g le problème c'est que l'absence
de votre mère est insupportable quand
elle vient un peu pour les vacances elle
repart pendant que vous dormez pour que
la séparation soit soit moins difficile
j'attendais je m'endorme et puis ma mère
partait soit dans la nuit soit au petit
matin
quand je dormais encore quand vous
rêviez était plus là qu'on voit là alors
vivez avec tout ça la drogue la mort
votre mère qui dit ton père nous a
laissé tomber
déversé temps vous commencez à avoir des
problèmes de poids qui sont dues à ses
angoisses là je pense que c'est que
c'est ça oui oui combler quelque chose à
11 ans après huit ans chez vos grands
parents vous demandez à retourner vivre
chez votre mère qui a fini par remettre
un peu d'ordre dans sa vie mais qu'il
est devenu maquilleuse de cinéma
c'est une bonne époque ça pas duré
longtemps mais ouais et vous êtes
rebelles
vous êtes viré de saint michel de picpus
donc 2e g sera encore une fois le ch ur
y est une fleur sur des bonnes soeurs
chez les bonnes soeurs c'est facile oui
évidemment
vous êtes aussi un peu complexes et à
l'époque je vais pas d'amoureux non je
suis la bonne copine en fait je vois je
suis la plus la bonne copie de tout le
monde je suis très jeune très populeux
voile à l'école au collège vous salissez
mais non dans les boums on m'invite jama
danse et voilà et puis à la maison même
si votre mère ne vous cache rien de la
mort de votre père le sujet reste tabou
on prononce pas son nom et quand un film
avec patrick dewaere passe à la
télévision ne le regarde pas un seul n'a
jamais initié à sa fin je vais changer
de chaîne je pense que c'était tellement
douloureux pour elle
c'est là à 16 ans que vous commencez à
découvrir la filmographie de votre père
le premier film que vous voyez ces coups
de tête et vous dites je me suis
vraiment marre et
j'ai découvert quelqu'un de différent de
ce que j'imaginais c'est vrai qu'en
général les films de patrick son sont
très noirs ça très torturée par contre
c'est quand j'ai découvert coup de tête
est la meilleure façon de marcher que je
vais pouvoir qu'il avait ce côté
comédie comique et j'ai découvert aussi
comme ça quand j'ai j'ai vu quelques
captation du café de la gare ont dû
s'éclater avec avec sa troupe au café de
la gare votre mère comprend vite votre
manque de motivation pour les cours de
secrétariat et de comptabilité auquel
vous étaient inscrits et elle vous donne
l'adresse du cours florent oui c'est
vrai que c'est ma mère qui m'a un qui
m'a poussé alors au cours florent ben
c'est pas simple vous dis-je était
verrouillée de l'intérieur
comme je sortais d'une éducation très
stricte un oui il fallait rester discret
ne pas montrer ses sentiments voilà tout
était
tout était à l'intérieur ça n'arrivait
pas à sortir et c'est vrai que j'aimais
beaucoup regarder les autres jouer mais
je voulais jamais passé sur sa faim
vraiment le prof était vraiment but de
devenir me me chercher et voilà j'ai pas
de très bons souvenirs de deux de ses
courts là j'étais pas prêtre je pense
hélas alors que vous venez de commencer
vos cours de théâtre dernier obstacle
dans votre vie vous êtes victime d'un
grave accident de voiture et 18 ans vous
rentrez un soir de boîte avec des amis
porte de montreuil la voiture heurte un
pilonne le conducteur est mort sur le
coup
et vous vous avez un arrêt cardiaque et
la bouche complètement arraché plus dans
plus de gens si oui oui oui j'avais un
trou je m'étais pris le siège avant
se voit pas un très bon chirurgien bravo
il faudra sept ans pour vous en remettre
mais les assurances pour diverses
raisons ne nous ont pas donné l'argent
tout de suite pour la voiture était pas
assurée voilà la voiture n'était pas
assurée
et donc voilà donc il a fallu attendre
de débloquer l'argent donc en attendant
j'avais un dentier comme les personnes
âgées j'avais un trou vraiment j'avais
j'avais plus d'eau depuis gencives voilà
donc je suis resté avec ça et ensuite
quand on a eu l'argent l'argent et s'est
débloqué
on a commencé les opérations de greffes
osseuses greffes de gencives et eu des
rejets voilà donc tout ça a duré très
longtemps le résultat est formidable
alors dans un premier temps vous rangez
vos rêves de spectacles au fond d'un
placard et vous trouver du boulot dans
l'immobilier donc gagner assez bien
votre vie finalement ah oui oui très
bien passé un mille euros par mois c'est
bien c'est ça ouais c'est bien il vous
manque quelque chose souvent j'ai le
sentiment de ne pas me sentir à ma place
tout le long de ma vie j'espère que là
c'est en train de changer mais oui je
savais qu'il y avait quelque chose qui
n'allait pas pourtant je me plaisait
vraiment très bien dans ce boulot et
puis je me suis dit voilà fetwa a fait 3
violence
démissionne j'ai été missionné décidé de
forcer le destin vous prenez le nom de
deux verres et vous vous lancez dans
l'acte or à ce moment là
tout le monde vous reçoit très gentiment
mais enfin dans les mois qui suivent
décroché aucun rôle et souvent on vous
dit revient avec dix kilos de moins que
rien on a même dit que je gère que les
gens avaient besoin au cinéma de rêver
quand on regardait une femme et que je
ne faisais pas rêver et qu'il fallait
que je perde absolument du poids sinon
je n'y arriverai jamais et un jour en
2010 myriam boyer mais engage dans la
vie devant soi
ensuite antoine beauville dans la
biscotte et charlotte de turckheim non
mince alors film qui a eu beaucoup de
succès qui a fait 1,3 million d'entre
être bravo 4 comme ça t'as rien
et c'est pour ce film que vous êtes
nommé donc aux césars dans la catégorie
meilleur espoir féminin on s'en réjouit
moi aussi
tous les soirs sur la scène de jaser
dans la véritable histoire de maria
callas si vous avez le césar vous le
désir et à patrick of course alors c'est
un peu à moi aussi ouais bah moitié au
fola moitié à les 20%
alors évidemment vous avez des séquelles
de tout ça vous avez des angoisses 1
comme beaucoup de gens mais vous quand
vous avez des angoisses vous buvez pas
vous vous droguez pas vous bouffer c'est
une jouissance l'arrêt moi je crois à du
chocolat ouais ouais ouais oui encore je
craquerais sur des carottes des
concombres c'est ça sa irai mais jamais
les carottes et les concombres le
nutella
j'ai compris alors voilà donc vous allez
bien le seul problème c'est votre mère
ça c'est pas régler encore
va se régler vous pensez
je le souhaiterais mais je pour
l'instant je me protège elle a des
circonstances atténuantes jeu
mais je me protège points quand je pense
à me protéger voilà toute chose
parfait quel destin incroyable
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux